Giulia May: Yeah.
Giulia May: Yeah, these are very cool.
Giulia May: Very cool.
Giulia May: Hello, hello! Good morning! How are you doing today?
Giulia May: So let me know! Hello!
Zoom user: Hello!
Zoom user: Let me know…
Giulia May: So, yeah, go ahead.
Zoom user: Oh, you can hear me, I don't want to interrupt. Should I turn off my microphone?
Giulia May: Well, when we start, yes, at this moment, we're just a few of us, so no worries, it's all fine.
Zoom user: I'm so glad I finally made it! I've been trying.
Giulia May: Thank you.
Zoom user: for a while.
Giulia May: Okay, great. I'm happy you're here, too. Are you a member already for a long time?
Zoom user: Yeah, I have already been a member, like, for 7… 6 or 7 months or something like that now, and I have not been able to do what… I got hurt at work, and… and you would think, being at home, that I would have attended. I was just trying to take a deep breath.
Zoom user: Hello.
Giulia May: Okay, I understand.
Zoom user: So I'm finally, finally ready to get going on this thing.
Giulia May: Yeah, very, very good. So, it's a good moment. I will show you around in a moment. We have Sandy, who joined as well, Jason, Billy, so very nice to meet you all.
Giulia May: I will do a tour of the whole community, show you around, so that you can get started and know what your next steps are.
Giulia May: I'm gonna wait a couple of moments more…
Giulia May: People are coming in. Hi, Livy.
Giulia May: Edric… So… and,
Giulia May: Let us know where you're joining us from, that's very nice, and make sure… I'm gonna add that as well, you are muted.
Giulia May: And then, when we're done, there will be time to ask some questions as well, so that's gonna be, nice as well.
Giulia May: So…
Giulia May: Okay, I will get started.
Giulia May: So, let me introduce myself first. So, my name is Julia, I'm one of the team members for a couple of years now.
Giulia May: I am not a grant coach, so I know everything about the community, I build it, and so I know how to show you around. I will point you at who are the people and where you will get answers for your questions.
Giulia May: But I'm super honored that I can introduce you on how to get started and where to find what.
Giulia May: So, the community has been rebuilt now for, I think, a couple of weeks now, so for people who are already a while in the community, they have seen a lot of changes going on.
Giulia May: But now we are in a new zone, and you will see additions, but not so many changes anymore.
Giulia May: So, let's get started.
Giulia May: at the right side of your screen, so you will see your picture, and there you can add or change, adjust your personal settings. I'm gonna talk a little bit more about that in a moment.
Giulia May: Then the little bell, that's one that I advise you to have a look at each time you join of the community, because there we have our notifications.
Giulia May: So that means upcoming classes, new things in the community. So it's definitely worth it to have a look and see what's happening.
Giulia May: Then we have our streaks. So, that's each day you come inside of the community. You, will get another checkbox. It's a little bit a way of being accountable, and it's nice to see your streaks growing.
Giulia May: So here, you see your search.
Giulia May: The community is rather straightforward now, so I don't think you will need it a lot, but it's there.
Giulia May: So…
Giulia May: for the people who are new, so we changed the banners at the top a little bit, in the sense that, depending on which stage you are on in your roadmap, you will see different banners. For people who are already longer in the community.
Giulia May: It's a little bit more difficult for us to, in retroactively, Catch where you're from, but…
Giulia May: look at it and see what's up there, because it's gonna guide you to next steps. Oh, many people joining us, that's amazing.
Giulia May: Hi, everyone!
Giulia May: So, then we go to the right side, so here we start with the real community. So, that's where we start to explore. So, what's new today, as well, have a look at, on a daily basis when you join the community.
Giulia May: Here, you will find all the upcoming classes, questions,
Giulia May: Matthew's videos, latest news, all that stuff. So go over it, have a little check.
Giulia May: Then… At the heart of our community are our classes, so that's super important.
Giulia May: Our experience is really the more you join classes, the better you get at finding your way in the community, but most… more important even, finding your way in the grand world.
Giulia May: I will explain which classes are for… are for which stage you are in. So, if you follow the roadmap, we will also advise you to follow certain classes.
Giulia May: So, imagine you have some free time on Sunday, you can click here, and then you will see the classes that we have on Sunday.
Giulia May: Saturday, and then see which classes would be for you.
Giulia May: So, that's about the classes, or the first part about the classes, and then, here, we have our roadmap. That is the backbone of your experience inside of the community. So, this is really the number one thing to follow along.
Giulia May: So, I will show you…
Giulia May: So, here, start here, do this today. So, when we finish the call, and you have the time to do so, do these three things. Complete your profile, adjust your notifications, and download the app.
Giulia May: You click here, and then it will open. So the page will open, like here, download the app.
Giulia May: I can see a lot of you are already joining from their phone, so they downloaded the app already. For the people who haven't done that yet, scan the QR code and log in with the same credentials, meaning your email address and password.
Giulia May: Then you have our community always with you.
Giulia May: So, that's, I think, maybe 10 minutes of work. The notifications is to, say or,
Giulia May: enable or disable the emails and stuff like that. Sometimes people complain that we're sending too much emails, and…
Giulia May: I sometimes have to be honest and say that we're sending a lot of emails.
Giulia May: But if you don't like it, you can disable it. At the other hand, then you don't stay up to date about what's happening. You can say, okay, no emails, disable that, and then have the app, and then you will have the notifications on your app.
Giulia May: That's possible as well. You choose, but you can decide to disable it.
Giulia May: Then, we have the roadmap, and the roadmap, you can see it here as well, has 7 different steps.
Giulia May: And so, that's… that's your road. This is what you follow. So, each step builds on the previous step. So, if you remember one thing from this meeting is that you need to follow the roadmap.
Giulia May: So, this is the community tour, so you are already, if…
Giulia May: Okay, I have been persistent, it's true.
Giulia May: So, here, the community tour, that's where you're at. So, that's already step number one that you can check off for today.
Giulia May: Then the next step that I want you to do after this call is to start creating your call sheets. What are your call sheets? These are your,
Giulia May: Lists that have been created specifically for you, for your situation, where you find all the addresses, phone numbers, names.
Giulia May: et cetera, of the organizations, the places that will help you with assistance or grants. Super important.
Giulia May: It's so important that we have created 3 ways for you, 2… Get… get grants.
Giulia May: So, I'm gonna… yeah.
Giulia May: So, number one is to join a call sheet. So, here you can see, good to know, 3 ways to get your call sheet. Go to a call sheet class.
Giulia May: make one yourself. So, after this meeting, you can go inside of the community and make your first call sheet.
Giulia May: And then the third way is ask that someone creates a call sheet for you inside of the question channel. I'm gonna go over all three of them together with you.
Giulia May: So, and I would also say, try them out, all three. They're here for you, and you will create several call sheets over time, so that you,
Giulia May: Are comfortable with all the different ways to get yourself a call sheet.
Giulia May: So…
Giulia May: First of all, not everywhere, but I created a lot of instruction pages as well. They're short, they're to the point, and they're full of tips.
Giulia May: And little tricks that we know that will help you greatly.
Giulia May: So, here, instruction on the call sheet classes. So, here we explain, again, what is a call sheet, why it's so important.
Giulia May: One important thing as well, so you create for each
Giulia May: Problem that you want to tackle a call sheet.
Giulia May: So that means, imagine you want to do something for cars, but also for your home, and maybe you also need some assistance or a grant for your business. Then you're gonna create 3 different call sheets, because otherwise it gets all mixed up, and it's way too complicated. So that means
Giulia May: One problem, one call sheet.
Giulia May: If you're not so clear for yourself, like, okay, what is it I need to ask for?
Giulia May: Then we have a little list here where we are… where you get… we have a lot of questions that you can, ask yourself, and it's gonna help you to create clarity on what it is you need to ask for. On top of that.
Giulia May: If you have a lot of things going on, which often happens when you are in need of things, it's most of the time not just one thing.
Giulia May: So, try to also put some priority on it. Like, say, okay, these 2 or 3 are the most important ones, that's the ones that I'm gonna do first.
Giulia May: I'm gonna set that in motion, and then afterwards, I'm gonna focus on the ones that are less critical at this moment.
Giulia May: Imagine, you are dealing with an eviction, and you have only a couple of weeks, and you're gonna lose your house, then that's going to be your number one, problem to tackle.
Giulia May: So, that's, about the instructions.
Giulia May: So here, we have our call sheet, classes. So, let me explain a little bit the difference between the two types we have.
Giulia May: So, on Saturday, you can join a Let's Go AI app class.
Giulia May: That's a class from Tony.
Giulia May: Tony is literally going to show you on the community… on the screen, I mean, on how to create the call sheets. He's also going to note down from people who are there what it is you need, and he is going to create call sheets, not during the call, because that's way too time-consuming.
Giulia May: But, afterwards.
Giulia May: And then he's gonna post them class information in the personalized class answers. There, he will add your name, and then he's going to add the call sheet that he created for you.
Giulia May: This is… I'm gonna give you a sneak peek on how a call sheet looks.
Giulia May: And so you can join his classes as many times as you want, and you can ask for several class… call sheets. They are made specifically for you. That means they're for your… where you live.
Giulia May: For your problem, and they really know what they're doing, so they're gonna really take a moment to sit, adapt the prompts a little bit, and make sure that this is really what you are looking for.
Giulia May: So, you have the organization.
Giulia May: Their website, contact information, etc. Dates of eligibility.
Giulia May: Description, 30-second call script, so it's really very elaborate.
Giulia May: So, that is, your… I'm in two places at the same time.
Giulia May: So, that's a call sheet, and so he's gonna create them for you, but in the class, he's also gonna show you how to create them.
Giulia May: Then, the other one, the blue card, or teal card, that's Roger. Roger is our AI wizard. So, if you go to his classes, he's also going to talk about how to create call sheets, but he's also going to talk about
Giulia May: how to prompt a call sheet, how to use your own AIs, how to become comfortable in using AI. I think these days it's amazing. The better you're at it, the better you're gonna have results for many reasons.
Giulia May: So, join both classes. I would say the AI workshop is more a beginner class, AI users skills is more intermediate.
Giulia May: And you can cycle back. So even if you're in the process already of asking or, yeah, applying for grants, you still can hop back into one of these classes, so even if you're further down the road.
Giulia May: So that's about the classes. So that's number one. After this class, this is one of the things. Choose the one that you're gonna follow, and make sure it's in your agenda.
Giulia May: So then, we have our AI Grand Searcher. That's Matthew's baby. He created this AI. It's full of everything he has gathered over the years.
Giulia May: And so, here, you go, you step outside of this class, and then you can start creating your own call sheets immediately.
Giulia May: So, what do you do? I'm gonna explain you how it works. So, choose, the type.
Giulia May: Imagine you need one for debt, for taxes, maybe you're a veteran, and you need specific veteran help, so create one for each topic.
Giulia May: Then add your zip code, or choose your state and your city.
Giulia May: Then you click this big button, and you run the research report.
Giulia May: it's gonna take a moment. So, let it just run. It needs to go to a huge amount of information, so it's not a 1-23 fix.
Giulia May: But once the report is made, it's gonna hop to results, and then you will have your list.
Giulia May: Here, you find the online list, you have email, phone number, website, but you also have a lot of additional information here, so that you can dive a little bit deeper
Giulia May: Who are these people? What are they doing? Is this really a fit? Research a little bit, go to their website.
Giulia May: Have some, take a moment to explore and to learn more about the different possibilities that are available for you in your area, so it's always local.
Giulia May: So, of course…
Giulia May: I would definitely advise you to export every call sheet that you create. Download an Excel, it's gonna look like the Excel that I just showed you, but you can also download a PDF if you prefer that, and then you can clear your report and make a new one.
Giulia May: So you can make as many call sheets as you want.
Giulia May: Little disclaimer, AI, unfortunately, still makes here and there a mistake. So maybe a phone number or an address is not 100% accurate.
Giulia May: It's incredibly well how it is now, but it still can happen. So, if you have questions, two things you can do.
Giulia May: or join a call sheet class, or ask a question in the questions channel. Then you say, like, hey guys, I made that call sheet, I tried ABCD, and this happened, and then the members, the team members will help you.
Giulia May: So, this brings me to the third option. That's our ongoing, questions channel. We have Misty and Rose here, who are working very hard to answer all your questions. Tony also is helping.
Giulia May: And so, what is, very important to know here, again.
Giulia May: One… one question, one problem for each post.
Giulia May: So, let's now say here, so share a post, so that's a question, basically. So, you will add your zip code.
Giulia May: your state.
Giulia May: Plus a description of your problem, or your question.
Giulia May: And so, that is going to be the incentive for, and then you post it, for the team members to go over your question, and then prepare their answer. So, it can be a call sheet.
Giulia May: It can be other documentation that we have, it can be a combination, it can be advice on specific things you can do inside of the community. They really take a moment to see what your problem is and what it is you need, and then they answer.
Giulia May: You will see sometimes the answers are really lengthy, and sometimes, like here, this is Misty.
Giulia May: She, sends com- information from inside of the community, etc.
Giulia May: So, this is the questions channel. Of course, this is not only for call sheets. So, any question you have along the process, and you're like, okay, I don't have time to join a meeting now, and to ask it
Giulia May: One of the team members, then you just ask the question in the questions channel, and they will come back to you
Giulia May: In 12, 24 hours at the latest, depending on when you post the question.
Giulia May: So, that's the number one thing you do.
Giulia May: After, you… leave this class is make yourself
Giulia May: the needed call sheet, so that's your treasure chest. Once you've done that, the next step is join an application class.
Giulia May: Because, of course, if you don't know how to apply, you will not have any results. So, we know it can feel daunting, I know it's scary to…
Giulia May: make the calls, how do you write an email, how do you apply in the form, the online, forms, etc. What to do with extra information. So, to get started, and to get a little bit,
Giulia May: Knowledgeable about how to
Giulia May: go about your applications, go to an application class and read the instructions. So, this is full of tips. It's not a long text, but make sure you have read it. It's gonna be incredibly helpful.
Giulia May: Next to that, you will find your application checklist here, so you can download it and print it out, and for each grant application that you do, you create a little dossier with a checklist, so that you can follow it up.
Giulia May: Because if you have done, I don't know, 20 or more applications.
Giulia May: then you want to keep track of what you're doing, and it can be a lot of administration to stay on top of things. So, here, go to the application classes, learn how to use the checklist.
Giulia May: And to really stay on top of things.
Giulia May: Before I forget, here on the questions channel, I have an instruction page as well on how to ask questions, so that's also one that you definitely, should read through.
Giulia May: To go back to the application class, we have here as well a scenario on how to make calls.
Giulia May: So, read through the 20, 20 phone call rule, and here you can also check every time you made a call.
Giulia May: And then here is a script.
Giulia May: Here are some smart moves when asking for money. That's delicate for all of us, so we… one way or another, one way or another, we have to get over it, and you will get used to it. So, in the beginning, it can feel…
Giulia May: stressful, but after a while, we have people inside of the community that have been looking for grants, because your life changes, and then you might need a grant for this, or something else, and that are very used to do that. That is almost like a lifestyle.
Giulia May: And there is a little video from Matthew.
Giulia May: That's about applying. Then, once you're a little bit familiar with the application process, your next big step is going to the group coaching calls.
Giulia May: So, why is this so important? So, again, here we have an instruction page, but we have a lot of,
Giulia May: group coaching calls. So once you're busy.
Giulia May: With applying for grants, you will have questions. Something comes across, how long does it take? I had a weird conversation, what do I do now, etc, etc. This didn't work out, what could be next steps, so these
Giulia May: Group coaching classes are super important. This is… the whole time you are asking, being… being in the grant process, this is where you go.
Giulia May: We have different ones, like with the grant clinic is open now, so you, if you want to, after this call, you can hop in and go and say hello to Amber or Tony, who are doing the, grant clinics.
Giulia May: So, this is just for any question at any moment. Every Thursday, almost all day, you can join us.
Giulia May: And then we have our Q&A Lives. This is for questions about your grants.
Giulia May: Anything that has to do with application, timing, whatever comes up.
Giulia May: Then we have our open office, that's more practical stuff, where do I find what in the community, maybe about your subscription, whatever you want to ask there. And then we have one specialized,
Giulia May: webinar that is very successful, and that is about how to go about paying my debt and bills. So most people, that's the most important or most urgent thing we are dealing with, so that's a very good class to go to.
Giulia May: So…
Giulia May: go to as many classes as you want to, even several a day. The more you go, the more you're gonna feel at ease.
Giulia May: the more you're gonna learn, not only from the answers that you get to your questions, but also hearing what other people are talking about and what they come across. So, it's a learning curve, but once you get a little bit deeper into the road, it's gonna get way more comfortable.
Giulia May: Then here, 7, it's a bit a bonus, so that's Matthew, he comes live in the community all the time.
Giulia May: And once a week on, Tuesdays, he goes live, definitely on a fixed moment, and you can join for any question. He's gonna be there, talk about what's going on.
Giulia May: In the grand world, what he came across, and then he's also answering questions from members.
Giulia May: He's very hands-on. He's gonna say, okay, that problem, go there first, then do that, and then do that. And don't get scared about this or that. So he's very, knowledgeable, of course, about how to go about the grants world.
Giulia May: So, then, for all the people that are here, that are looking for…
Giulia May: improving or starting a business, a nonprofit, or doing a career change. This is our business hub.
Giulia May: So, we have, information sheets about…
Giulia May: So here you can see Boost Your Career.
Giulia May: Start a business, and each time it is a lesson.
Giulia May: And quick guides. One or two lessons and quick guides. So, I am in the process to modernizing this whole environment, so it's not fully done.
Giulia May: But what you will find here, like here there is a video from Matthew. He advises,
Giulia May: he advises the members to also make an appointment with a local coach or counselor. So, you will find that information on many of these, different, places.
Giulia May: Where he explains for health, or for housing, business, nonprofit, etc, because people, these coaches, these counselors, are very knowledgeable how things are done in your region.
Giulia May: And they are… they have a good coaching, mentality.
Scott Napier: He is sweet.
Giulia May: So, and it's nice to talk to a human, right? So, it gives you a feeling of having more support, not being alone, so if possible, if available, do that, absolutely. That's a very nice thing to do.
Giulia May: And then the quick guides, you will see, so the, the…
Giulia May: call sheets we create for you, or you create with your… with the AI, they are local, so they are based on your zip code, your city, your state. But all the quick guides that you find here are federal help, so that's, like, two layers.
Giulia May: So, these are also super important, and go over them, and as you can see, you have a checklist as well, and each one of them
Giulia May: You can download them, print them out, and start contacting these organizations.
Giulia May: So, you can check it off then. If you're done, there are some tips, you can add notes on the printed version. But it's also a very nice addition to find, additional support.
Giulia May: Then, so this is for non-profits.
Giulia May: It's for business, and it's for career.
Giulia May: here we have the Lesko Pro group Coaching. These are the group coaching classes that we have. If you have a business non-profit, or you want to start a business or a non-profit. So.
Giulia May: it doesn't mean you shouldn't go to the other classes, but this is an addition, so if you're exploring, it's like, you know, if there are challenges in your life, finding ways to add to your income is also very nice. So that's what this zone is about.
Giulia May: improving, starting a business, changing your career. You will see here two of the grant coaches who are working here. Amber has her own business. Megan has several non-profits.
Giulia May: They know this whole world from that perspective, in and out, so that's super cool.
Giulia May: And so you will love to get to know them.
Giulia May: So then, we have here a class replay, so you can imagine you're a big fan from Megan, and you want to see all her classes, then you can go back.
Giulia May: And then, watch the recordings.
Giulia May: Then here, this is what we already have looked at, the personalized class answers.
Giulia May: Then, we have a very large library. So, this is the same system as what I showed you before, with the lessons. Most of the time, not always, with a video from Matthew.
Giulia May: and then downloadable, quick guides. There are places where I didn't have the time yet to create the PDFs. They are coming, so in the next couple of days, weeks, they all will be up there.
Giulia May: But here you can already see that we have these federal help.
Giulia May: Quick guides, also ready for you for healthcare, taxes, legal, family, disabilities, cars, homes, etc.
Giulia May: So go over them, choose the ones that are applicable for you, download them, and add them to your grant search. So then you have your call sheets at one side that's local, specialized for you, and then you have your quick guides that are federal help. So that's a very, very large and complete
Giulia May: set of organizations that will be.
Scott Napier: We're genes, I'm praying, Father God.
Giulia May: So… Then we have here,
Giulia May: Safety warnings, not so important anymore. We had some problems with outside of the community, not in here, but impersonators of Matthew, but that's way better, so, we have not a lot of activity there at the moment.
Giulia May: Then, I would like to show you that we also have only one member chat, but if you wanna say hi to the other members, chat a little bit, etc, then this is your
Giulia May: place to be. Don't ask questions here. Like, Denalia has, shared a question here. They will change it, but that's not the place.
Giulia May: Then community updates, that's…
Giulia May: upcoming events, things we want to share. I'm creating some super cool tools for you guys that I will post soon, then you will find it in here.
Giulia May: Here you find Matthew's latest videos. These are mostly his videos that he's creating for Instagram. So.
Giulia May: It's not specifically for inside of the community, but you never know that it's exactly that that you need.
Giulia May: And then we have here as well, we look for grants all over the US, all the time, see if we find something that is interesting, you will find them here.
Giulia May: So, if I go back quickly, number one, follow the roadmap.
Giulia May: So, you've already done your welcome tour. Number two, create your call sheets. If you need two, create 2. If you need 10, create 10. Explore our 3 ways to get to your call sheets.
Giulia May: Once that is done, go to an application class and read the instructions, and then once you're on the go, go to the group coaching classes as many times as you can.
Giulia May: So, that's a little bit the roadmap, or the way we work inside of the community. And now, I'm gonna open the floor for questions. So, if you have a question for me, please unmute yourself and just ask.
Giulia May: And then I will try to help you.
Giulia May: So… Don't shy out, I'm not gonna…
billy: I just want to say thank you for clearing things up for me. That was great.
Giulia May: Okay, that's amazing, I'm happy that worked.
billy: You cleared up a lot of questions in my head. I've been staring at this for days, and…
billy: Now I…
Giulia May: Yeah.
billy: Have a better understanding.
billy: Thank you.
Giulia May: Yeah, I so understand. It's so overwhelming, right? When you enter, it's so many things, and colors.
billy: I look at it like, okay, wow, alright, this is great, though. Thank you.
Giulia May: I'm happy it helped. Yeah, and come back anytime if you have questions. So, there are people who are joining the welcome tour several times, that's fine as well. But all the other people who are doing classes, they will help you as well with questions.
billy: Thank you very much.
Zoom user: I have… I have never, opened this on my computer, only on my telephone.
Zoom user: Is… can… is there any way you could give me the,
Zoom user: the… the… what I'm supposed to go to, the web address to get.
Zoom user: To this page that you're showing?
Giulia May: Yeah, so what you're asking me is how to join the community on my computer.
Zoom user: Computers.
Giulia May: Yeah.
Zoom user: Yeah.
Giulia May: I'm… I'm gonna share it here in the chat.
Giulia May: Cool. So…
Giulia May: It works better, so this is the link, and what you will see is a landing page, and at the top right, there will be a sign-in button. And when you click that, you use, under the account name, you use your email address, and then the same password.
Giulia May: What is a little bit tricky as well, because it's Mighty Networks, it's not, it's a platform that we use.
Giulia May: So, you will see sign in with a code, but then you can… three buttons under that, you can sign in with your password. Just click that, add your password, and you're in on your computer.
Giulia May: It's more comfortable.
Giulia May: on a computer, the phone using your app is super easy. If you're on the road, you want to join a meeting on your phone, that's perfect. But to do the work, to really look what's here, what's there, download stuff, it's gonna be so much easier on your computer, yeah.
Zoom user: I have been noticing that.
Giulia May: Yeah. I have one.
Zoom user: just… just seeing what you were doing right there, I was like, oh no, I… I can't… it's not the same for me here at all.
Zoom user: And so, I'm going to try it right this minute. Enter.
Giulia May: I'm always full of admiration when I see people who are using the community on their phone all the time, how well they do it, but it's… it's… it's tricky, because you need… you have only that… that amount of space, right?
Giulia May: Yeah.
Zoom user: Right, right. And it obviously doesn't open up, it's not giving. And also, I don't… my glasses and my eyes just don't work like they used to.
Giulia May: Yeah, I'm sorry.
Zoom user: Inside… I'd like to get… I'd like to get money for glasses.
Giulia May: Exactly, that's the spirit.
Giulia May: Anyone else who has, questions for me?
Giulia May: So…
Zoom user: Okay.
Zoom user: Thank you very much for taking the time to do this.
Giulia May: Of course, I'm happy to do that, and I'm always super… before, I only saw community building, and now I am super happy that I'm also doing some classes. There is one class that I think that I will do in addition soon as well.
Giulia May: is, I would like to do a role-play class to exercise how to make the phone call. So that's something you can see happening, and then we can do some really nice exercises together to get over…
Giulia May: the feeling of, oh my god, how does this work? So… and that's a lot of fun.
Zoom user: I have a question, I have a question. Have people ever, like, formed groups in their area, you know, gotten together and formed little groups?
Zoom user: you know, locally to watch you guys…
Giulia May: Super cool idea. Yeah. Not that I know, but I think that's a great idea.
Zoom user: I think it would be really motivating to show up, you know. Of course. I would do it.
Giulia May: That's a very good idea. You might see something happening around that, because at the end, it's so nice to have people around you, and have some accountability group, and that you can organize yourself, and…
Zoom user: Yeah.
Giulia May: We can maybe work together at some moments, yeah.
Giulia May: Fairly.
Zoom user: And to support each other, you know, I don't know, I just… I would show up. If that… if that ends up being true in my area, which I think might be more likely than others, because I'm in a populated city, I will show up, so, okay.
Giulia May: Fantastic. Okay.
Giulia May: So, I will do a short little recap one last time, so then to make sure it's, like, very well embedded.
Giulia May: So, the Explore the Roadmap is your backbone, so go… if you're lost, like, okay, what's my next step? Go back here. So, once you've done all the steps here, this is going to collapse, and then you only have your roadmap.
Giulia May: Check it off, one by one. On the little cards, we explain each time what it is you do, and this is just what you follow. It's like your map.
Giulia May: And then here… here are all the steps.
Giulia May: read the instructions where they are. You will see me making some additional changes still, because it was a huge amount of work to get all the things restructured, but we're almost there.
Giulia May: And, go to as many classes as you can, and ask as many questions as you can.
Giulia May: So, whatever's on your mind, never shy out, never think, oh my god, is this a good or a bad question? Don't worry about privacy, do not ever give a phone number or an email address, but for the rest, this is a safe environment.
Giulia May: You will be well taken care of, and we only want one thing, and it's see you all succeed, and be successful in finding grants.
Zoom user: I really believe that.
Giulia May: Yeah.
Giulia May: Okay, thank you so much for being there. I hope to see you soon again, and thank you for your presence, the questions, and I wish you a wonderful day. Take good care. Have a good day. Bye, everyone.
billy: Aye.
Giulia May: Have a good day, all!
Zoom user: Hi, thank you.
Giulia May: Bye!
Olive: Thank you.